[Music]
don't look at that oh yeah I had
dreads in college 24 how are you
I'm 34 I'm 10 years older than you
ha that's not hot yes it is yes
experience you lack experience you'll
see we will not feed martini perfect
we've got everything what do you want
Scot we don't have that but we have
flavored vodka no these are my roommates
[Applause]
this is a portal to help nope can you
put your phone away work was garbage
today I can't just please her baby what
did it show you nothing
can we just let's just drink wine and
watch TV or boom and don't do video
games yeah Oh even slower slower than
you can possibly imagine
okay all right
what is it I cleaned your bathroom oh
thank you
do you love it yeah how's this
sorry okay I don't really want to come
anyway baby are we hanging or chilly I
don't understand the question
I got really exclusive yeah you're my
boyfriend yeah no I knew that you're my
cover I've had a girl from before no I
don't know
[Music]